y un paso más en la defensa de los
derechos de los animales colombia
prohibió las pruebas de cosméticos en
animales es el primer país de américa
latina en impulsar esta legislación
organizaciones como animal defenders
celebraron la medida victoria
prohibición de pruebas cosméticas en
animales ya es ley en colombia
la industria cosmética en américa
latina' facturan más de 63 mil 200
millones de dólares maquillaje cremas
antiarrugas champús y otros se utilizan
en millones de animales para ensayos una
práctica que ya es historia en colombia
una pionera en el mundo del surf
katyusha se convirtió en la primera
surfista profesional de senegal ahora
aspira a participar en los juegos
olímpicos
y siempre veía a la gente ir a surfear y
me decía pero dónde están las chicas que
surfea pensé porque no voy a surfear
represento a mi país
represento a áfrica represento a senegal
como una chica negra porque nunca he
visto a una chica negra surfeando bien
murphy que álex surf también se ha
convertido en una fuente de inspiración
con su escuela chicas negras surf donde
enseña los secretos del deporte a las
más jóvenes
[Música]
el río ozama de república dominicana
recupera su aspecto natural
después de años de recibir toneladas de
basuras de las industrias de
santodomingo han instalado el
interceptor 004 una plataforma que
navega contracorriente a baja velocidad
atrayendo plásticos que flotan en la
superficie una forma de limpiar uno de
los ríos más contaminados del caribe
[Música]
un gran descubrimiento para la biología
en galápagos la segunda reserva marina
más grande del mundo fueron descubiertas
30 nuevas especies de invertebrados como
langostas y corales que cuentan con una
reserva marina de 138 mil kilómetros
cuadrados la investigación en este área
protegida ha sido intensa sin embargo
hay muchos ecosistemas que han sido
explorado el hallazgo se produjo gracias
a la tecnología tras descender aparatos
hasta 3 mil 400 metros de profundidad en
un mundo subacuático todavía por
descubrir
[Música]
un cumpleaños especial sin zinc la panda
más mayor del mundo cumplió 38 años una
edad comparable a humanos de entre 110 y
140 años un hito que bien mereció una
gran celebración en el zoo de chongqing
en china
[Música]
no